so
but i remember going into into the st
city and not seeing my name on the
marquette said no y'all got to put my
name on the marquee well tom jones is
here next week take his name down you
got to put my name on if i'm performing
tonight and they thought his [ __ ]
arrogant he's crazy what i was doing was
building a brand i wanted people to
remember the name name had to be on the
ticket i wanted to remember the name
wasn't that i was trying to be arrogant
i'm trying to build a brand you don't
see coca-cola walking around saying
don't put coca-cola on that we're
building the brand right when the brand
was the name so with that with ownership
and then watching oprah realize that she
owned her show i was like okay i'm not
selling anything i'm gonna own
everything when you say you watched
oprah you watched oprah do it you
watched
is this you as just a student a suit i
didn't know yeah it's a family [ __ ] i
remember reading an article about her
owning her show and i said what did that
mean because she had she hadn't
renegotiated her show with i think it
was king world where she had gotten
ownership i'm like how did she what does
that mean what does that mean and then
i'm like how is she making all this
money oh because she owns it and because
of syndication
she she might get mad i said it so i'm
just going to tell you she she
sometimes she said you know there were
times i was getting checks that i
thought were social security numbers
they were so big you know what i mean by
the way
yes i believe it yes right and yes
yes
yes that's information that needs to be
given because the shock factor yes now
for being friends now it's incredible
because i can call her up at this point
in her career in life and we really lean
on each other for a lot of things like
hey
this this and this is going on and this
oh i went through that in 86 here's what
you do you know having that kind of
information right or calling up recently
and saying hey you know there's
something going on with the studio where
it's just this what they're trying to
get me to do is huge and it's it's it's
kind of
wild and it's amazing and she's like you
know i think you should do it because i
did this this and this and it seems like
the new version of this this and this
the the thing that
also acts as a intriguing factor for me
with you is it just keeps progressing
right and we're coming from the world of
plays we're coming from the world of
sold-out shows and opportunity that
comes after i find out now that you when
it made you went took the meetings and
after taking the meetings you figure out
the best thing that works for you
i'll tell you what happened with that
real quick i just
went to all these different meetings
they were like we want to change this
they're talking about our matt blackman
was like i'm not changing anything we're
going to change this you got to add this
to the script they said i'm like but you
you're white you don't understand this
is what the audience wanted so you were
you were selling you were taking the
material to them yes at the time okay so
yeah to a couple of studios okay and it
just didn't work so i called charles you
know i'm out going atlanta selling down
to my trunk and i get a call from mike
pasternik over lionsgate and the reason
he he said
uh called me is two things happen that's
why that's why i love when we we come
together on the same page he was leaving
uh uh a show and i had just played the
kodak theater and
the black people
crowding around trying to get to their
cars and he goes hey what'd you guys see
tonight i think tyler perry he had never
heard of me right so he goes to the
office the next day right he goes to the
studio at lionsgate and he has a meeting
with dale hughes and he says hey man
have you ever heard this guy tyler perry
i was like man this guy's huge all over
the country i get a phone call saying
hey uh tyler he came he wanted to do
this movie what do we have to do i said
to that i was so pissed i said listen
i'll put up half the money i'm going to
own 100 of it and that's it and charles
comeback said tyler they're never going
to do that i said well [ __ ] i don't care
come back say they're going to do it
you